I need one place where I know all 837
000 are definitely gonna see this
because I'm getting guaranteed delivery
that makes a ton of sense it's why I
continue to have an email service and
it's why I have Community detect service
I'm extremely excited for this next
guest uh I think this will be a very
fruitful conversation and I think uh
it's going to bring a lot of value to
this specific uh podcast that we're
putting out this special so my friend
why don't you tell everybody your name
what you do uh and then we'll get right
into it
my name is Eamon Hariri I'm the CEO and
co-founder of Vero so for the people
that don't know out there uh why don't
you tell us what Vero is and a little
bit about the history
so Vero was established as a an
alternative social Social Network online
that
really differentiates itself mostly by
not doing uh any ads or data mining so
we have a chronological feed creators
can post what they want to their
followers they gain access to 100 of
their followers without the platform
manipulating the feed in any way so it's
a fully chronological feed and um we're
not doing ads we're not in the attention
economy at all we're in the subscription
uh business we haven't turned
subscription on to anybody that joins
Vero today gains access to Pharaoh for
life without ever paying a subscription
but then when we turn so there's the
Arbitrage Dustin get that BMX Channel up
now if because he's going to clearly
turn on subscription at some point but
you can be locked in in perpetuity yeah
in perpetuity that's right
noted go ahead and then later on when we
do turn on subscription it's going to be
a very small amount that people will pay
a yearly fee or a monthly fee and it's
really for us to just keep the the
platform honest for us to be serving our
users having them be our customers
rather than advertisers be our customers
where we have to constantly try to get
the attention of the users to use the
platform so that they can see ads so
what's your take on this question do you
believe that the subscription so we as
people who post on social will be paying
9.99 13.99 29 9900 whatever it ends up
being
um but we get 100 of the audience that
decides to follow us to see it which is
extremely different than it is today
yeah more like email right exactly right
do you believe if I asked you for
foreshadow for me do you think in 10
years that a Creator like myself do you
think I'll have one of each meaning or
I'll probably be on several platforms
but or or not do you actually that's
actually the question do you believe
that most people in 10 years will have a
social network that they're paying for a
subscription and one that looks more
like the ones that are out here today
where there's an algorithm and ads and
things that nature or do you think one
or the other beats out the other in a
model yeah it's a it's a it's a great
question question I'm not here to
replace everything and be the be-all
end-all with our platform I think what
we're trying to establish is is choice
and a choice that gives you more value
for the time that you're putting into
the into the platform whether you're a
user and our customer using the platform
and getting the most value for the time
that you're spending or a Creator like
yourself who's spending time making
content thinking about ideas thinking
about a roll out having a team and all
of those how does the user get value so
the user should get value for the kind
of content that they're getting whether
it's
um
it whether it's
content from their friends that's
personal and meaningful to them at that
level or from creators that are
providing value to them through the
whatever it is that they're getting
across whether it's entertaining whether
it's teaching them something whatever it
is but that's something they're able to
get in other platforms now absolutely
okay but without the ads and without all
of the which is exactly for a lot of
people no absolutely so from the user's
side the people consuming no ads high
value products in comparison to what's
out there for the creators uh there's a
value in that everyone's gonna actually
see it of the audience imass absolutely
um is there is there ways to offset your
subscription costs yeah that's an
interesting question so we just recently
um we recently acquired a company called
tokenize which is a regulated Stock
Exchange and you may say okay what
what's
why is a social network buying a stock
exchange and the whole idea there is for
the community
to end up having a chance of owning a
piece of the platform and doing it in a
regulated way that has us do it where
it's all legal and you can start to earn
shares in the company now details uh
will come out in the future in the near
future I mean we just acquired this this
company and we merged it into into the
social network and it's really the first
time anybody's done this and where our
heads at is we're building this for the
community we're building this for the
rest of the world not for us to own and
reap the benefits of that by ourselves
but for us to be joined by the creators
who get to earn a piece of the platform
by bringing in people who start to pay
for Content or pay for their channels or
whatever else or pay for the app but
also for those users who are coming in
and making a decision that they want an
alternative platform they're paying a
subscription you know wouldn't it be
great if they could earn shares in the
company as well
take me back to the history of the
platform because I know
you know and I notice how quickly my
team shakes their head because we watch
everything and I mean everything there
was a moment of what I would call Micro
virality for this platform can you take
me back to when that exactly was because
it feels like five or six years ago
right and what you know a how deeply if
at all were you involved at that point
because it's blurry in my head if like
you came in later and bought a piece or
you're actually there for day one you
know like I could see by your body
everybody listening to body language no
no so you were there what what was
behind the micro virality of it because
there was a few minutes there where it
was really spiking and and it was
happening for a period of weeks or
months I remember very vividly sure and
and this is a big compliment there the
in the history not what I feel like I'm
gonna be in like a lot of documentaries
when I'm older in the history of social
networks obviously we know the ones we
all know
there's things like Vine that really had
it but they've sold in a year uh and
unlike what meta did with Instagram
Twitter decided to shut down Vine
um but there are very few social
networks that have even gotten to that
point where they've had a moment what
was that and and obviously after it
happened it was probably easier to
figure out why it happened or maybe not
because virality is interesting but
what was that when was that and and how
did it happen yeah it's uh I I've
definitely been there since day one I
can show you the scars on my back to
show that and the white hairs in my
beard uh to also show that but um what
happened in 2018 and that's when uh the
virali yeah 2018.
if covet I feel must have made me like
God was it really only as re I would
have like lost that bet yeah I thought
it was longer than that when did it come
out so 2015 is when we put it in the IOS
app store I think I might have wrote an
article and it came uh after that on
Android and now we're on iPad and
desktop and desktop is a beta for the
for the time being in Android as well
but we're coming out of beta soon on
Android
so uh in 2018 what happened was we we
were experimenting with ads like we were
actually just trying a few ads and
letting people know about us uh to
increase the number of of installs per
day and just see if we you know what
would happen if we put out a message
that says no ads no algorithms and no
data money that's it I mean that's the
chronological feed yeah we just put
those those four uh phrases in different
uh small video clips and just put them
out as ads
and um
and I didn't spend that much on it
either and as you said we became number
one app in the world
that's crazy so it it was really I think
it we we turned all the ads off at that
point because we couldn't handle the the
load that was the major part that um
brought things back down but we we sort
of learned from that that it doesn't
take much
to especially with what it is that we're
doing
to get a lot of attention
and I think now more than ever people
are seeking an alternative we haven't
done
any real advertising since then yes and
we made a decision a conscious one to
build the tech stack that is scalable
to keep building on community which is
what we've been doing so all the growth
that you're seeing in the platform the
six and a half million users and above
that we have now have all been organic
um and now we've just introduced the
investment stack which we're very
excited about because well it's a
massive Innovation well and it it gives
a return for the time that you're
spending on social especially for the
creators or bringing so much value to
the platforms that they decide to use
but they don't get access to the equity
value in the platform they get different
value they do they get different value
which is it's actually Jerry rigged on
to the existing platforms because of
course it's sponsored posts it's this
and that or the stuff they do off
platform or the stuff that they do on
platform like Fame is real yes so once
you build it like Charlie demilio makes
a lot of money because of what happened
on Tick Tock outside of things she does
on tick absolutely but to your point for
a smaller group this infrastructure
would create an extreme long tail of
opportunity correct and we're going
after the everyday creator that wants to
make money and wants to make
um a living off off of the thing that
they're passionate about and they don't
need that much but what's interesting is
when we look at you know if I if I sit
and told you right now that somebody had
a thousand followers you'd say okay that
that's cool but you know that's on the
the Lower Side of the the Spectrum
you've got people who've got hundreds of
millions of followers and so but I mean
of course to anybody who wants to make a
living doing it absolutely for a lot of
people listening right now like I'm
[__] kill for a thousand followers no
absolutely for normal every day but like
of course if someone wants to make a
living a thousand is going to be on the
extreme low side exactly and but when
you start to look at uh whether it's
subscription or you start to look at
backers of your project whatever that
may be that's a lot of people who you
know who I always I love you for that
because man back in the day I was like
do you understand what 80 115 people
that want to see what you have to say
looks like physically
you put 815 people in an auditorium and
you speak in front of them you know
you'd be like holy crap I made it but in
this world you're like I'm an
imposterous into my son I'm like you
don't suck but to your point you know as
we go into the Commerce part of the
conversation with the blockchain
enables potentially over time uh and
obviously when I hear you talk about
what you're talking about it's famous of
what's going on in the U.S with the SEC
and what's going on in Europe like
clearly the governments around the world
Hong Kong this and China that and you
ask this the regulation and the the
understanding of cryptocurrency and nfts
is kind of a little bit unclear it
seemed clear and it got it kind of like
took a step backwards seemed in 1920
like things were kind of pretty obvious
with coinbase going public and things in
nature but clearly we've taken a step
back of like you know people just don't
know what so obviously you going
specific to you know an actual stock
market enables you to actually
punch those two together yeah absolutely
I think how does that work for people
that live in countries where it's not as
clear like obviously the stock market
that you bought is not in the U.S right
that's right right so like what does
that mean for someone that lives in
London or for someone that lives in
Amsterdam or for someone who lives in
the U.S will they have is there gonna be
a little period of time of clarity if
they're gonna be able to interact with
those Commerce realities yeah we'll make
all of those things clear whenever
anything that happens on the stock
market we'll make sure that things are
clear but definitely going down the path
of Regulation gets you there further
it's harder to do obviously upfront but
it's nice to have Clarity exactly and
then you just have
um a system just as a guy paying
attention since you did that what you've
got to tell you on like what's your bet
on the governments around the world to
actually have Clarity on
cryptocurrencies and blockchains and
nfts which are hot take do you think
it's another two three four years of of
you know politicking and government
stuff before we as a society of 8
billion have Clarity of where and what
and how we can do things look I think
there is Clarity around what is a
security I think the the problem is is
that we're we're starting you know we're
what's colliding right now is are us
being used to things happening quickly
yes and being able to be instanced on
the internet yes and for that to be the
disrupting uh force and enough of a
disruptor that all of this old you know
sort of law or whatever it is gets
changed yes the reality is is that these
things have been put in place to protect
investors yes so these laws
are there to Def or rather to back up
the usage of something called the
security and the security is one of
actually one of the best inventions in
the world it allows us to own
shares in things that exist and we get
to back them and we get to reap the
benefits of them so
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to marry that concept with this endless
supply of creativity that's out there
whether it's the creativity that uh
creates a song that could be a hit or a
movie
um or any kind of business and hopefully
in the future we've had Publishers yeah
Publishers absolutely players Banks
upfront economics right exactly and
obviously the blockchain is going to
have an incredible opportunity to create
innovation in that scheme yeah and and
all block what blockchain does you know
all blockchain does or or what it does
extremely well is add that layer of
transparency that's the number one thing
and I look at web 3 as a it's actually a
set of behavior it's not a technology
stack it's people deciding they want to
include other people into the project
that they're doing and be completely
transparent and use blockchain as a
transparency on the back of a profound
new technology on the back of a profound
new technology that backs up if the
concept of transparency I agree if
people understood action
what a what a blockchain did versus a
internet server yes
the speed in whichever it actually is
addressing what everyone's anxious about
but it's misbranded absolutely yeah and
but at the same time there's a lot of
work that has to go in in advance it's
kind of like of course you know it's the
difference between playing pool a
Billiards pool and just hitting the ball
and something goes in and you say look
something went in yeah you have to call
it out ahead of time you have to say
here is what I'm doing I'm building a
business that does this this is what you
can expect everything's at you know
there's risk associated to everything
Etc but this is the kind of business
that I'm in or this is what this uh
piece of art looks like or or is valued
at
Etc and the more you can be transparent
ahead of time and then stick to what it
is that you're doing then the outcome
then is you know for everybody to
benefit from
um
parting shot what have we not talked
about
in this time together that you'd love
for people to know about you the World
blockchain Vero creativity subscription
or all of the above I guess if if
there's a parting thought it's we're
building we're building for better we're
not here
um you know saying we have all the
answers or we're building an alternative
platform that is the platform that will
take over from every other platform
absolutely we want it to be one of the
biggest platforms uh in in the world
right now and to be an alternative right
why not to be a viable alternative but
what we are doing is we're coming from a
place that says look things have been
done in a certain way up to now and we
think that it's one-sided it's a win on
one side we're always trying to create a
win-win a win-win but for creators for
the users of a platform for the platform
itself and for everybody to join and be
able to whoever does decide to make a
move and come over to our platform they
get to have a winning you know it's
funny and I by the way I look my
favorite word in the world is and
instead of or favorite but I will say
one thing I I am fascinated by how much
value I do think people get from free
social networks that have an ungodly
amount of human beings consuming you
know I think it you know we talk about a
Charlie demilio or Logan Paul but Jesus
there is a very long tale of human
beings hundreds of thousands yes who
make hundreds of thousands of dollars a
year B being influenced on any platforms
that cost them nothing sure right I
think what's exciting is I really don't
think it's as one-sided I really don't I
think it's more of a game of and than
one-sided I I for example immediately
interested in the concept of having one
of my platforms guarantee that all you
know I would rather have Vero is a
compliment to all my other social and I
have a lot of social yeah sure right of
course I'm sitting here and thinking and
I'm like I'm getting so I'm like hey I
better sign up now so I have to pay the
[__] subscription fee let me give
them get a little microarbon but I'm
like you know what this is gonna be
awesome it's kind of like how I use
Community the text message service sure
um I'm like I'd love to have one social
network that only has a million this is
my standards only a million the others
have more because not everyone listening
actually wants to see actually every
piece for me they're fine following me
but they prefer it right and I do a lot
of different stuff line and jets and
this but that'd be really cool that's
like something I actually need I need
need one place where I know all eight
hundred thirty seven thousand are
definitely going to see this because I'm
getting guaranteed delivery that makes a
ton of sense it's why I continue to have
an email service and it's why I have
Community the text service right exactly
so looking forward to checking out for
myself everybody you should check out
Vero Vero yeah uh and like in the app
store that's how it is yeah in the App
Store in the Android store and uh we
have an iPad app and a desktop app for
some data so I know a bunch of you
especially the Instagram crew of 2018 I
know a bunch of you might actually have
this on your phone because you were on
it for like a hot minute uh would love
to hear from everybody hit me up on
Twitter at garyvee on your feedback on
this and or or do you think the social
world will be in a five ten year window
subscription only uh the way it is now
and no subscription Services come to the
top 10 or DC it the way we've talked
about here with and where there is a
subscription player and there is and
look only fans patreon right sub stack
like there is literally content being
made that people pay for and so
um and and in your world it's actually
the person that's making it that's
paying it paying right the subscription
no actually so everybody gets to
everybody pays a small fee and that way
it makes it sustainable
the idea though of marrying it with this
um tokenized Stock Exchange is that
everybody also gets a piece of benefits
put the uh blockchain to the password
above a lot of people's pay grade in the
short term but will become normalized
soon in the in the step one though I'm
not down I mean as you can imagine I'm
very excited about what you're talking
about there
um
everyone pays eventually hasn't happened
yet as I heard from you that's right
anybody that signs up pays yes but pays
a very small amount understood as
opposed to and is there any different
Dynamic if you're a high volume creator
of output or does that happen because of
the second and everything yeah so if
you're if you're bringing a ton of
traffic yeah we're not going to charge
you more of course or anything like
we're posting more or posting more or
access to more people because right now
you're posting but you're only gaining
access to about three percent of your
audience in our case you gain 100 access
to them what about virality
yeah framework is based on emails don't
go viral you
I just aged us yeah the kids don't
[__]
folks uh
boy kids no [__] in the late 90s
yeah like pre-social networks if you got
people used to send random funny emails
to their entire dress book and then
people would send it like email was like
early social like you would actually
forward reply all forward anyway back to
the point so cool but a lot of people
have benefited by having no audience
going on Tick Tock posting and then boom
800 000 that's been very beneficial to
them
is there a viral component to Barrow
that yeah I think you're talking about
Discovery and Discovery is something
that we're so we're building it step by
step and Discovery is absolutely
something that we're building into it so
if you're somebody whose content is
being seen by a lot of people and is
having a great reaction when you're in a
discovery mode you can go and discover
that kind of content and then you just
discover the new creative not in your
core feed because you've chosen you only
choose who goes into that by the way
that's how social started totally it's
obviously evolved into an AI driven
Discovery Model and clearly is effective
because people do like passive Discovery
sure but to your point I I can speak for
myself I am actively still a person that
has to rely on email and my you know two
one two nine three one five seven three
one sign up now because I need a place
that quote unquote guarantees it because
if I want to post something that I want
everybody to know about and I post it on
social I gotta work super hard to make
that creative as [__] which is almost
inherently impossible you want people to
know every single time selling so it's
really interesting stuff brother thank
you so much thanks for having me
[Music]
foreign